vous jouez avec jean pierre marielle
c'est une très vieille amitié ça va oui
si la complicité de la première fois
c'est un sport qui est venu je jouais au
théâtre dans un théâtre d'élèves c'était
au centre dramatique de la rue blanche
je jouais néron gt1 l'armée j'étais
entre au conservatoire lui pas encore
j'étais donc il faut dettes et je me
souviens d'un lieu d'un sergent de
l'armée de l'air qui est venu et qui m'a
dit monsieur c'est vraiment très bien ce
que vous faites at il dit j'ai été très
impressionné et on m'a dit c'est un
élève du conservatoire voir marié elles
en auront fait un souvenir
extraordinaire qui me poursuit depuis
des décennies et avec mon cadeau de
troufions je suis allé le féliciter
nous sommes restés amis
elle soir je suis rentré chez moi j'ai
dit à mes parents il ya un élève du
conservatoire qui est venu me féliciter
mon père m'a dit ça c'est très bien à a
c'est la première rencontre avec
rochefort
[Musique]